[Musique]
beaucoup de monde ce matin là au musée
départemental de villèle 330 assistants
familiaux ont répondu présent à l'appel
leur employeur le département de la
réunion
parmi elles maryvonne un sourire au coin
des lèvres
elle a commencé ce métier en 1978 il ya
40 ans ca fait des tours de l'éducation
des enfants l'amour à tout beaucoup
d'amour sur l'apa d'amour fait pas ce
métier mais l'accompagnement ça a bien
évolué au niveau du département
on se reconnaît on a suivi meilleur
parce qu'il ya la formation iliad et où
on peut rencontrer quand même nos
collègues et les charge de la
communication pour moi c'est une grande
importance à la réunion 877 assistante
familiale accompagne 1867 enfants placés
de 0 à 21 ans et ce jour là les discours
donne toute la mesure de ce métier de
ces êtres que nous avons le devoir de
faire grandir et s'épanouir quoiqu'il
soit les adultes responsables
demain je suis conscient de vos
responsabilités de votre engagement à
concilier votre vie privée et vos
obligations professionnelles et
départements en force aujourd'hui son
équipe de référents professionnel pour
avoir l accompagnement plus de proximité
et nous demandons également le cas des
services sociaux étaient encore nous
d'être dans une relation plus étroite
avec des assistants familiaux d'être à
leur écoute de savoir on va dire
échanger sur le niveau de problématiques
les accompagner dans les prises de son
et surtout accompagner la prise en
charge par lors que l'enfant soit les
traités le muet possible un moment des
changes est également de convivialité
ponctué par l'intervention d'humoristes
pays qui savent toucher juste également
un moment de répit pour celles et ceux
qui sont au coeur de l'action sociale
les métiers que ces personnes exerçant
des métiers difficiles
oui il faut donner beaucoup d'amour à
des enfants qui parfois ont connu la
souffrance et donc moins à titre
personnel mais tous les élus s'associent
à moi ou à leur rendre hommage
aujourd'hui à travers cette page web
[Musique]
c'est en chanson que ce moment c'est
ponctué preuve une fois de plus que ces
hommes et ces femmes savent travailler
au quotidien avec leur coeur n'ont pas
droit
je souhaite à tous les nouveaux 22
prendre ce métier-là bienne à coeur est
ce que c'est vraiment éboué et paris et
les outils au mieux